can i ask you uh
a pothead question which is uh what is
money man
so if we just kind of zoom out and look
at
i said let's talk to you about
cryptocurrency which perhaps could be
the future of money
in general how do you think about money
you said numerai
the division the goal is to to run
to manage the world's money what is
money
in your view i don't have a
good answer to that but it's definitely
in my personal
life it's become more and more uh warped
um and you start to care about
the real thing like what's really going
on here
um elon has talks about things like this
like what's what is a company
really it's like it's a bunch of people
who like kind of show up to work
together and like
they solve a problem and there might not
be a stock out there that
that that's trading that represents that
what they're doing but it's it's not the
real thing
um and being involved in crypto um
like i was early i put in crowd sale of
of ethereum
and uh and all these other things and
different
crypto hedge funds and things that i've
invested in and it's like
it's just it's just kind of like it
feels like how i used to think about
money stuff is just it's just like
totally warped um
because you yeah you kind of you stop
caring about like the like the price
and you care about like the product so
but by the product you mean like the
different mechanisms that money is
exchanged
i mean money is ultimately a kind of
little you know
on one is the store of wealth but it's
it's also a mechanism of exchanging
wealth
but that like what what wealth means
becomes a totally different thing
especially with the
cryptocurrency to where it's almost like
these little contracts these little
agreements these transactions between
human beings that represent
something that's bigger than just like
cash being exchanged is 7-11 it feels
like yeah
maybe our answer what is finance uh like
you it's what are you doing when you can
when you have the ability to to take out
a loan
you can bring a whole new future into
being
with finance if you couldn't get a
student loan
to get a college degree you couldn't get
a college degree like if you didn't have
the money but now like weirdly you can
get it
with and like yeah all you have is this
like loan which is like so now you can
bring
you can bring a different future into
the world and that's how i when i was
saying earlier about if you rerun
american history
economic history without these these
these things like
you're not allowed to take out loans
you're not allowed to have have
derivatives you're allowed to have money
um it would just it just doesn't really
work and it's a really magic thing how
how how much you can do with finance by
kind of bringing the future
forward finance is empowering it's uh we
sometimes forget this but yeah it
enables innovation it enables big risk
takers and bold
builders that ultimately make this world
better
you